Hello, music.
My brain waking up.
Hello.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm not okay right now.
I was like, oh man, I'm a little tired.
Let me take a little nap.
What's the worst that could happen?
Oh my god.
Oh, I was... I felt like I woke up from a fucking...
Why does this always happen?
Every time I'm like... Oh, so look at that.
I could actually get a cat robot butler.
But like, every time I'm like, I'll just take one tiny nap.
Just one...
One tiny nap and then things will be okay.
Things will be so fine.
I don't... I don't know.
I feel like...
What world am I in?
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm like that movie from...
That Disney movie where he's like, here I are.
What movie am I are right now?
The post nap hangover is... I'm fucking... I'm going through it right now.
I'm going through the post nap hangover, but it's okay.
It's Tora but time.
Sumimasen.
My favorite type of... Okay, so like, I haven't done... Okay, so history behind... I've talked about my history with like crane games before, but like when I was growing up, my dad and I were so obsessed with like crane games in Japan.
I remember like, obviously the crane games now in Japan are a lot harder now, but that back then, like if you say like, maybe like 15 years ago, crane games in Japan were super fucking easy.
To the point where like, maybe like 15...
Yeah, 15 plus years ago.
Because like, it was a lot easier to like, when pride... Oh, this is how my brain feels right now.
This BGM is literally my brain right now on loop, on feedback.
And you don't even need a sumimasen.
Like legitimately, you don't need a sumimasen people back then in Japan for crane games.
So like, when I was growing up, my dad and I brought back, like when we went to Japan, we all we did was just play crane games.
And then we brought back, because my dad, he doesn't care about the prizes.
He likes the thrill of it, you know, like people who are like really good at crane games that just they don't play for the prize themselves.
They just love the thrill of winning, you know, so like that was my dad.
For me, I just like the prizes.
So the chase.
Yeah, yeah.
So like, we brought back one point.
I remember we brought back like two suitcases full of prizes we won from crane games.
And like, some of these prizes, my dad didn't care, fucking care, like what the prizes were.
He just like, I would got have like plushies of weird of like things.
I don't even know what it's from.
Like, I just be like, it'll just be plushies of like, like shows or games where I was just like, what the fuck is?
I don't know what they were, but we brought them back.
Because like my dad see like big prize and he'll be like, I can get that.
So my dad taught me how to do crane games.
Because he's like, I shall pass down my knowledge to you.
But then they got harder.
They got a lot fucking harder as the years go by because I guess like Japan was like, oh, hey, maybe, maybe like, you know, we should try and make money off.
Like, maybe we should start, you know, making money off of this game instead of like, you know, making it so easy, like, you know, they might, I don't know, it was, it was more so like, let's make this harder, like actually, so we don't lose money.
So I remember one time, like the last time we actually like spent all our money on crane games was when we realized that they started rigging them.
Well, I don't want to say rigging them, you still get it, but it's definitely a lot more harder.
Like the skill jump just went insane.
So you know how like people would be like, oh my, level one is so easy and then level two is like, like final destination, like.
They're just like, they're like, all right, level one, baby mode.
Level two, it's time to learn how to kill somebody.
Like, that was what, um, that was what it felt like, uh, the last time we did crane games together.
And then like, we just never, we just, we would just like, if we were in Japan together, like when my, my, me and my dad would go to like one arcade and just see how rigged it is.
But like, that's every arcade now.
Um, so like, um, it takes like, you know, several tries and stuff like that because it's like, there's like, you know, you got, even if you're like pushing your prize down or like, um, like you have to scout out machines and stuff like that.
But even then, when you're like, my dad would used to scout machines out too.
They're like, he would scout out machines and see which prizes are easily dropped.
But even then, the claws or like the game itself is still like not, it's still harder to win.
Um, it's still a lot harder to win.
Yeah, for those who don't know machine scouting, some people who play crane games or Toroba, they would scout out the prizes and stuff like that to see, like, they don't care about like, you know, they could, some, a lot of people resell some of these prizes from Toroba too.
Uh, uh, and then they just sell the prizes to like the store or sell it out on the sidewalk outside of the, of outside of the arcade stores.
So there's no point in actually, like a lot of people who actually play the crane game is just for the thrill of winning a prize from a crane game.
But you could actually get a lot of these prizes just like for discount and stuff.
Um, just, um, for discount just from like outside or like outside the arcade.
Uh, and so yeah, and then like, you know, we played a couple of them and then we realized, whoa, this is a lot harder now.
So instead of like winning, you know, two suitcases full of plushies from one arcade, we, from one, like from several arcades, from one arcade, we only managed to grab like one or two plushies, like one to three plushies.
And then my dad gave up.
My dad's crane game career ended that day.
It was like, it was like, it's not the same.
It was, it was just not the same.
The thrill was gone.
The spark in his eyes was no more.
Yeah, and then I remember my last time playing like crane game series, not seriously, but like when I still had joy from crane games, like even though my dad's spark was gone, I still had joy with crane games.
And like, it was, I remember this so fondly, um, because also let me know the BGM is okay if it's too loud, but like, I remember this memory so fondly because, well, not fondly at all because there was so much pain afterwards, but I remember it when I first,
you know, okay, so it was a Raichu, oh my god, somebody got the fucking robot cat butler.
Holy fuck, okay, anyway, so, um, I was at an arcade in Japan with my family and, um, there was a Raichu sleeping plushie, like, that it was supposed to be like an exclusive limited edition Raichu sleeping plushie and it was like pastel color and everything.
This is like a flashbob, it was like a flashbob memory for me because like, oh my god, I, I still remember it and I was like, I was like, I need this, it's so cute, I really need this.
I don't know how many tries it took me, but like, I sumimasen, I didn't even know what the fuck sumimasen is.
I, at that time, I've yet to discover the power of sumimasen because I didn't even say sumimasen back then.
I was just like, excuse me, like, and then he, like, he, okay, and then, like, he came over and then adjusted the Raichu for me because, like, um, I, I wasted so much money.
I, I did not know how much money I wasted.
I just, I just remembered.
I didn't even say sumimasen because I didn't know what the fuck that is.
I just, I was so desperate.
I called an attendant to, like, help me because I was so desperate.
I didn't know the sumimasen thing existed.
That was how desperate I am.
I literally discovered, I discovered sumimasen because I thought he, I wanted him to pity me.
Anyway, so then I kept doing it and then I still wasn't, I still, and then he was watching me too.
And he was just standing on the side just watching me.
So I still, even though he, like, adjusted the plushie, I was still trying to, like, get it, but I couldn't.
I was, I don't know why.
I just, I just, I just didn't, I just couldn't get it.
And then I wasted even more money on this one machine.
By the way, this was one machine.
I spent, like, an hour on this.
I think I spent, like, an hour just standing in this arcade for this one machine.
Like, I don't even know if it's an hour.
Maybe I'm over-exaggerating because it felt like a fucking hour.
Anyway, so I kept doing it and then the tenant, he felt so much pity for me that legitimately I got, I got pitied so hard that he came over, opened the, opened the machine, and just gave me the plushie.
Like...
It's like, enough money.
I reached, I reached hard pity.
He unlocked it and then he just, he just gave it, the plushie to me.
And then my mom was so happy for me that she took a picture of me holding the plushie in front of the machine to commemorate them all.
She was like, oh my god, you did it!
And then, and then, so you think this is the end of the story, right?
Um, you think this would be the end of the story, but it wasn't because when I got back from Japan, and this is where I used to live in Hong Kong, when I got back from Japan, um, I was at home and then my mom was, like, shopping at a market and there was,
like, a, um, a Japan special, it was, like, a Japanese special event in this Hong Kong mall.
And then she was, like, she texted me and was like, oh my god, they're doing, like, a special, uh, they're doing, like, a, there's, like, a special sale right now going for, like, Pokemon stuff.
And then she was like, do you want anything?
And I was like, oh, okay, yeah, sure.
Like, what do, what do they have?
And she took a picture and there I saw it.
It was a fucking Raichu plushie.
There it was.
It wasn't just it, it was, like, other Pokemon.
It was from this Pokemon Pastel Sleeping Series.
But I saw that Raichu plushie and it was, I would say, it was definitely a lot cheaper than whatever the fuck I spent on that crane machine in Japan.
Because I was told I was, oh my god, there's Sumimasen available.
Anyway, I was told that I need this cat butler.
That it was a limited edition plushie that was exclusive to crane machines.
But I forgot that in Hong Kong, they don't care about that shit.
Sometimes in Hong Kong, they would, like, malls because, like, instead of they'll, like, purchase the stock for it and then they'll just sell it because they're just like, well, we don't have crane machines but we do have the stock for these Pokemon plushies from our supplier and they'll just fucking sell it.
They'll just, they'll just fucking sell it.
Like, oh my god, like, if you find those limited edition, like, if you find, okay, if you find those things in Japan, they'll do, like, those lottery things, like, you know, 7-Eleven or, like, a family mart and they'll have, like, lottery stuff where you do a lottery and then you can win those prizes or stuff like that.
And, and then, like, or, like, these, like, items that are very exclusive to, like, uh, prize games and shit like that, you know, like the crane prize figures or the prize plushies, you'll find it in Hong Kong in the store, like, and for a lot cheaper.
And it'll be, like, official too, like, it'll be, like, some fucking, it'll be, like, special event and I'm, like, oh my god, you'll find it in Hong Kong, 100%.
Like, you can even buy it too, like, you don't even have to do, like, the, the prize thing, you don't have to do, like, the prize thing where you have to, you know, they'll, they'll have it in Mong Kok, they'll have these stores where you can do the prize things where it's,
like, a lottery and then you open, you, you go in a box, pick up a number and then see what the number is and the number of, like, it'll be, like, number A, like, or letter, it'll be, like, letter A and then, whoa, the grand prize, here you go, but you can just buy it.
You can just skip all that and then be, like, I just want this and they'll be, like, okay, and they just give it to you, like,
you don't, you don't even, you don't have to do the whole fucking, um, you don't even have to do any of it, that shit, they're just, like, here's money, they're, like, all right, here you go, so, oh, man, oh, and it made me, it made me so sad, because,
like, you know, in Japan, I, I thought, I was, like, I spent so much money for this, so exclusive, uh, so, so exclusive, right, you plushie, and then, literally, he shows up in Hong Kong, like, uh, like, a couple of weeks later, I, there's, you can't,
there's no, there's gacha, people who gotcha there, it's just, legitimately, it's just a thrill to gacha, you know, it's just a fucking thrill,
but you can just, like, you're happy, here's the money, I just want this person, I just want this, all right, sorry, I, I got very, anyway, that's why I remember this experience very, very not fondly, because it was, like, the fact that I played it for so long,
to get hard pity, just for to see that fucker show up a couple weeks later, and, like, I could have just bought him, like, I legitimately just want, I didn't care about the thrill, I wanted it because it was so cute, and, like, I was, like, oh my god,
it's so cute, like, and it's exclusive, there's no other way to get it, silly me,
silly me for thinking that there's always a way to get something with money, and that's when I know that that's also the day I learned that, like, that's when I learned how, how strong the rich are, that money is everything, but you can just pay your way for your thing,
the things you want, just throw, just throw money at it, that was the day I learned, money is power, I learned, I learned how life works, anyway, I've been looking at this for, like, the longest time, guys, I don't know, like, I, I, I don't know, like,
it's, I just, but it seems so hard, like, how do I get the sumimasen, I don't remember how to sumimasen, but it does say assist available, so I just gotta spend enough money, so, like, I don't know, I just want the infra-controlled food delivery robot,
it just seemed, it just seemed so silly, like, oh my god, 58, what, oh my, okay, I'm gonna fucking get it, this, like, uh, what, like, I'm just gonna throw money at the problem, too, all right, let's go, all right, let's turn down the music, uh, we don't need bgm,
we have our own bgm, I'm gonna go fucking crazy, all right, how do I play this, what is this game, I should have, okay, I don't know how to play this game, okay, I'm gonna figure this out, um, how the fuck do I play this game, did I fuck it up already,
like, am I supposed to get that, like, what is this,
like, like, what am I supposed to, am I supposed to get this, like, oh, no, okay, all right, I didn't need that, I didn't need, that was my tp practice, that, wait, it was this, what is this for, okay, wait, what is, oh, it does B, me and I, oh my god,
off to a good start, I, I can't tell, am I, I'm supposed to get this, right, okay, I want a cat butler, though, what am I trying to get, I want, oh, it's B, I mean, it's orange, I mean, they're both the same, I just, okay, all right, let's try again, all right,
I want you, little guy, there you go, can I pull, push this, is this pushable, oh, it is, it's pushable, all right, I don't know, I saw a towel, I, I was like, I, I don't know, I, I don't know, I just, I, I see, like, so many crane games where you gotta pick up some shit with these,
like, loops on it and then I was like, oh, man, oh, man, that, that's basically, that, do I pick up the towel, like, like, I see so many where it's literally abuse picking up the towel and I just legitimately thought that's where it goes, oh my god, okay,
I, I know what to do, I just have to, I have to push this, it can't be that difficult, it's just legitimately just, it was a, I just realized this cost a thousand eight hundred, I just realized,
I just realized how many points this, okay, guys, no, it'll be worth it, I'm gonna get a robot butler, guys, I'm gonna get a robot butler, it's so worth it, oh my god, is she, sumima sending me, oh no, it's just an emote, god damn it, okay, I'll be fine,
I just realized that, stop, stop, I know, stop, I can't, I know you're, I know you're judging me, I know you're judging me right now, okay,
okay, I know, I know you guys who are browsing right now are judging me, I know you're balking me right now, okay, okay, oh man, okay, I need, okay, my limit is a hundred, okay, I'm gonna, I don't know, wait, I spent forty dollars already, it's okay, so like,
I'm gonna max out, it's gonna be, okay, oh my god, how do I do this?
Should be, am I close?
Are you serious?
Fucking get down, oh, where is my, I played four times, how do I not have my sumimasen, it said assist available, it says assist available, am I being lied to, where is my assistance, like, okay, I need to move it up more, like, I need to push this,
I should be able to push it now, right, come on, push it, okay, okay, we're slowly getting there, all right, that's close, technically, that's closer, that's, that's, that is closer, guys, that is, guys, do not tell me it's, guys, do not tell me, no, guys,
you don't know that, you don't know that, that, yeah, this is exclusive to Torobut, this is,
this is, this is an exclusive cat butler and on Torobut, all right, okay, there we go, we should be able to get it now, this is push worthy, this should be push worthy, right here, okay, I don't think I can, I need to move, like, oh my god, I should, I should move more,
I should move more, wait, this should be it, yeah, oh, come
on, okay, okay, okay, all right, no, no, no, I figured it out, I figured it out, I figured it out, I should have moved just a little bit more, there we go, that's how much I should have moved, and then, and I should be able to push this, all right, all right,
okay,
okay, wait, am I supposed to push it to the yellow?
No, I'm pushing it there, am I, wait, no, I'm pushing it, okay, no, okay, there we go, okay, I was gonna, all right, okay, I'm doing it right, okay, I, somebody was saying that I'm doing it wrong, I might be, I might, I might be, but I'm like, oh, man,
how wrong exactly am I doing it?
You know, I got a little scared, I got, legitimately, I was like, I worked so hard to push this all the way here, I got, I got very scared, oh, my God, it's too weak, it's so weak, oh, my God, how would it go over the edge?
Please, I just want my little robot butler, has he not seen how much money I've spent?
Oh, my God, okay, okay, okay, no, no, no, no, no, it'll be fine, all right, okay, we'll be fine, okay, it's gonna be, okay, that's fine, we'll just push the little bits here, all right, come on, Trillian, come on, oh, oh, oh, no, I went backwards, what do
you mean, what did I do?
You are not vulturing me, I swear, you are not vulturing me, I swear to God, I will fucking find where you live, I'm not gonna vulture this, you are, I'm gonna be here forever, I swear, if I will spend a hundred dollars on this machine myself, like, how fucking dare you,
oh, okay, okay, okay, okay, guys, guys, guys, I know, like, I know it looks like I don't have the money, I, guys, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I, I'm good for it, I swear to God, I am, I'm good for it, guys, I swear, I'm, I am good for my money, I, I swear to God,
like, you are, you are not, you are not, don't, two people, oh, I still have time, I have 284 seconds, you think you got me, oh, you're not taking, I will make sure you watch me play this game until I get it, you are not taking my robot from me, oh, shit,
I might not move for a little bit, guys, I might not move, all right, I need to make sure, okay, uh, oh, I just put the code in wrong, oh, no, oh, no, okay, uh, all right, there we go, there we go, uh, Ivy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you,
and so it begins, it's okay, I got the money, I told you, I'm good for my money, I told you, please, please, let me, let me keep my knees up, please, okay, there we go, no, I do, oh, I do, I told you, I'm good for my money, I fucking, I fucked up my crane,
I fucked it up, but like, I told you, I don't, imposter snake, thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you, average spender on Torobu here, assist happens when you spend a certain amount TP on the crane game, assist will reset when you leave the game,
however, you can keep getting assisted until you win the prize, assist activation is random, where is the man, where is he, can he not see me suffering right now, where's the staff, where the fuck is the staff, oh, you're not vulturing this shit, I'm,
you're gonna watch me do this until it's over, you're gonna, next, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, you might be good for it, but are you good, concern, it's okay, we're gonna be here, I will figure this out, I will figure this out,
where is my sumimasen, is this assist available, where is my assistance,
okay, I don't care, you will be mine, I will spend a hundred dollars on this one crane game,
oh my god, I'm gonna, I'm gonna push it, I'm gonna push it now, I'm gonna push it, I'm desperate, I'm pushing this, I'm gonna push it, maybe I can push it with my little hands, maybe I can, oh my god, sorry, I did not push, I didn't push the way I wanted to push,
not like that, okay, okay, maybe, stop, I know what you're thinking, I know what you're thinking, I think I know exactly, oh, one person left the queue, because he knew I was determined, he fucking knew I was determined, oh my god, okay, all right, maybe I'll go from the right side,
oh, oh, okay, all right, maybe that's good, what, is that, is that, is that good,
maybe, all right,
oh, wait, I'm getting closer, it's getting a little closer, it's heading there, all right, all right, all right, I figured it out, okay, and then I just need to push that part, there you go, come on, oh,
okay, okay, all right, that's okay, that's okay, I, it's technically a little closer, you can, it's sort of, you can see, it's like, it's, you see that, it's like a little closer now, you know, it's like just a little bit closer, here we go, here we go,
I set it back, now it's touching it, we're, we're so back, we're, we're back in the game, we're so back in the game, no, do not, okay, guys, do not,
do not look at this, guys, I know you really want to look at this, but
all right, now you can't judge me anymore, now, this is a can't of you,
where is he, where is the man that resents this, that's suing my sins, is this a sys available, am I being, oh, oh, oh, wait, wait, wait a minute,
you can't hide your shame, now no one knows, now no one will know, wait, okay, okay, welcome to the tomato farm, welcome, okay, okay, how do we do this, guys, okay, how do we do this, how, how do we do, this is the run, aim for the center, all right, I fucked up,
okay,
okay, this is technically the center, right, okay, there we go, I, I, I didn't fuck up, it's sort of there, it's fine, it's fine, nothing happened, which is the best part, nothing happened, I just reached your head, okay,
this has to be the center, this has to be the center, right here, no, no, no, no, no, why did, why did it go backwards, wait, wait, why did it go back, no, no, don't do this to me, don't do this, okay, I push,
okay, wait, this is doable, it's up the ramp now, guys, I got it up the ramp, this is so doable, it's up the fucking ramp, all right, I put it too far up, but that's okay, okay, I fucked it up again, but that's okay, there's no way it's gonna reset it,
all right, no, no, no, no, it's up the ramp, guys, it's up the ramp,
you got Uber Eats, why do you need a food delivery robot, you don't understand, I want the robot to deliver this from my door to my office, you don't understand, you know, I need it to deliver from my door to my room, if I'm gonna be rich, I want to feel it,
I want to have the real experience, if I'm gonna be rich, okay, now I should be able to push it down, right, now I should be able to push it down, you're not getting rich,
okay, wait, maybe if I can push it down here, this should be where I can push it down,
it's okay, it might mean nothing happened, but like, but like, but that's good, that's good when nothing happens, guys, that's good, that's good when nothing happens, guys, all
right, so, I just want my cat robot, I don't understand, that, I just want my cat robot, I just don't understand, it's like nothing happened, no, no, no, no, no, it's not over, it's not, could someone stop me, they said assist is available,
where is it,
I don't, I don't understand, he said a man would come over and help me, where is he, where is he,
a man is watching and he's laughing, please, how do you guys see how much money I have, I don't, are you physically calculating the amount of points I use, that's so fucked up, you're like physically calculating in your head how many points,
oh my god, next scene, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, this will be a great opportunity to use a dead inside, no, I'm not dead, I still have hope and optimism in my eyes, no, it's not dead yet, it's not dead yet, I still feel hope in this world,
oh my god, I don't need a
scoff, fuck you, that's right, oh, you're gonna, oh, keep playing, oh, no, no, no, no, no, I want you, come back, come on,
play the game, I watched, play the game,
I played, it only took me 60,000 TP, so fucking easy, so, oh my god, only 60,000, oh, jesus christ, look at that, now, I get a cat Butler, that's a top quality value right there, what a deal, guys, what a fucking deal, That's right There was a man here.
He watched me.
Sorry.
Oh, nobody's gonna play it now.
Oh Wow, you fucking vultures Wow, no one Coincidentally is gonna play now.
Come on.
Show me how it's done.
Do it.
Fucking play the game.
Show me how it's done Just wait until it's free.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm gonna have a cat buzzer.
Oh, he thought it was the towel, too!
He- oh wait, no.
Look at that!
Didn't even fucking hit the thing.
Oh my god.
Wow You didn't even hit it That's fucking right She's so- at least I- okay, at least I thought it was the towel You can't say that Show me how it's done.
Show me.
I don't- I don't- are you gonna give up?
Are you also gonna give up?
Look at that.
Wow, that's fucking right.
You thought it was so easy You- you thought this game was so easy.
Doesn't even hit the thing Are you getting toxic?
There was five other people that were waiting for me She's motivating him Mmm You're gonna give up?
You're gonna fucking cry?
You're gonna give up?
Oh my god, give it up already?
The toxic is rising
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So this is where all our super chat money goes to enabling my Oshie Thank you for the super chat Duck, thank you.
Johnny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Sue me my sense on is currently out due to personal life problems and will not be back until an unspecific date and time Thank you for the super chat.
Oh, no one else is gonna play then show me how it's done Oh, wow, you guys no one's gonna show me how it's done Wow, where's my skilled Crayol?
There you go.
That's right.
Fuck you.
Show me how it's done, man
Oh No, you gotta push it sir, you gotta push it
In a game you coward vultures So badly The only dumb one, but you were persistent girl.
Thank you for the rain.
Thank you.
Thank you I'm trying to see how they get Wow.
Oh my god.
Do you have eyes?
Oh, I'm sorry
How do I emo in this game guys, how do I how do I emo?
Oh, wait, I can poke it guys.
How do I emo guys?
I need to know the clap
I Can't click on the cat.
Oh, that's right.
That's right.
Oh go go go.
Wow.
You're doing so good
I do enjoy this.
Do you enjoy?
That's a key, right?
Oh my god.
Yeah, that's a key, right?
I Guess no, oh you're gonna give up now.
You gotta cry to your mom.
You're go back to the chat crime Be like, I'm sorry.
You were right.
Don't you it's so difficult.
That's fucking right That's what I thought
You want to cry
Ivy I can't believe her peak toxicity is
I won't do it again, I'm sorry.
Just don't ban me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
During Torova of all things.
It's okay, guys.
I'm back in.
Guys, I said I was sorry.
Okay, I like how there's a sleeping bag prize that you can get.
I'm a sportsman-like conduct.
I got a yellow card, but that's okay.
I told him I was sorry.
Okay, I said I'm sorry, so it should be fine now.
I should be allowed to play video games again.
I'm sorry, I didn't mean it.
I just got too absorbed into the thrill of this.
I got too absorbed.
There's a Furby?
Oh my god, wait, that's so cute!
Wait, this Kuromi plushie is so cute!
No, Doki, you have too many plushies.
Wait, is this another plushie?
Is this another cat robot?
Liz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Dojo.
I know you don't really need it, but here's some Toroba funds for you.
Also, Toroba Sasan, do help Doki get some prizes.
Also, Sasan, don't panic.
She did nothing wrong.
It's not like I went to their homes and be like, You're fucking dog shit!
I didn't say that.
I just yelled in my own home.
Like, it's different.
It should not be the same thing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's not like I threw a fucking rock through their window or anything.
Like, I didn't do that.
I'm just a little guy.
Vox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you for my evil gremlin Hoshi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know what to get.
There's so many, like...
It's just, you know, there's so many choices that you just don't know what to get type deal.
And you're just overwhelmed because there's just so many choices.
Alright, let's see what the new ones are, latest.
Let's look at the newer prizes and see what they have.
Okay.
Oh, that's so cute.
That's really cute.
But like, it's also $1,800, so I want something cheaper right now.
I need... I need... I need to play something cheaper right now because I...
It was a little... We might have spent a bit too much earlier, so I...
I want a cheaper one just for now.
Oh, man.
Why is this $4,000?
Oh, my God.
Wait, but it's smaller.
Who the fuck is Little Fluffy Friends?
It's smaller than Donald Duck.
Like, it's smaller than him.
It is cute, though.
This is cute, but like...
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, the... Oh, my God.
The little night light.
The room light.
You can filter by... by prices.
Okay, let's look at the cheapest one.
Okay, where is it?
How do I filter by prices?
I don't think you can.
I don't see it here.
Yeah, I don't see the by prices thing.
Doki can get really competitive with almost any game.
I wonder how she would do in Hopscotch.
Here's some Sumimasen.
Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can look by price?
Where's by price?
Like, what is it called?
I'm looking at it.
I don't see it by price.
I'm just gonna look from here.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I want this.
Wait.
Oh, you don't see it.
It got cut off.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna show you cats.
I really... I sort of want this.
Wait, let me check.
I'm gonna check the others first, and then afterwards, if none of them appeal to me, I'm gonna clean game it.
You'll see.
You'll see when I press it.
You'll know exactly what I want.
You'll know exactly what I want the moment you see it.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, my God.
The pastel Doraemon.
Alright, let's see.
I'm looking at it super fast, though.
Alright, okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna get that one.
I'm gonna get it.
I need this.
I...
I... I need this.
Wait, how the fuck... Wait, is there assistance?
Wait, give me a... Wait, before I go for... Okay, assist is available.
Okay, I... I... Okay, alright.
Somebody do this for me.
Somebody make it closer, and then I'll join the queue.
I'm so stupid.
Why do I do all the hard work when I can have...
C'mon, any Dragoons wanna help me out?
C'mon, c'mon, just help me out.
Just, you know, someone make it closer, and then I won't say I'll vulture it.
Okay, guys?
I think vulture is such a harsh word.
I'll... I'll come in and... and finish the job.
It's like a collab.
Who wants to collab with me?
Like...
Any... Any Dragoon wanna collab with me, guys?
Look, I am... It's like a collab.
I come in and finish the job.
Liz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
One more thing.
I typo'd.
I mean, doki.
And do you prefer the ping pong crane game or the normal grabber?
Speaking of which, wouldn't it be cool if they added more types of games, including three call?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't like the ping pong one, because like, it's... It's... I feel like there's more money being spent on the ping pong.
Come on, guys!
Come on, Dragoons!
It's open collab, guys!
Oh my God!
I'll even shout you out.
Alright.
Don't worry, I'll go in.
I'll join the queue with you.
Look at that, now I'm in queue.
Alright, how do you do this?
Okay.
Oh, he's like pushing it.
Oh!
Okay, you just made it harder.
I swear to God, if you leave after that...
Okay, fix this.
Now you have to fix this.
Now you're nice, you made it more difficult.
No, you don't fucking leave.
You don't fucking leave.
He's like thinking now, he's like, oh shit, what do I do?
You don't leave.
You don't fucking leave.
Fix this!
Thank you for the reset.
You got...
Where's my shoutout first?
Fix it and then you get a shoutout!
Fix it!
Oh, you're gonna wait out the name?
You're gonna wait it out?
We all know what you did.
We all saw it happen.
There's still another guy in front of me too.
He'll fix it.
We already told you it's a trap.
Come on!
Get in there!
I didn't realize it could get worse.
I thought like, I thought that was the reset.
I didn't know this man came in and actually reset the whole thing.
I can wait.
You think I haven't been waiting my whole life?
I can fucking wait.
That's fucking right.
That's right, know your place.
That's...
That's fucking right.
Oh my god, this guy has a...
This guy has played so much Toroba that he has his own emote.
Who the fuck is this guy?
Oh my god.
That's a Toroba regular.
He has his own fucking staff that I don't even have.
Like...
Yuki is the one who waits.
Holy crap, that's a pro.
That's when you know he's been playing.
Pro, get in here!
I know you're not in the queue, pro player.
Get the fuck in here.
Curse of Ra...
Okay, okay, now it's still worse.
Okay.
Oh, you are not leaving.
You are not leaving.
We're gonna watch this.
Queuing for Toroba for two hours is crazy.
Come on.
He didn't fix it yet!
You didn't fix it!
That's not fixed!
It's the same one!
Fix it!
I said fix it and then you get your shoutout.
You literally just moved it the same way, but like to the right.
Get out of the queue.
The other Dragoon will fix this.
Get out of it.
All this for a muscle bread bear.
Oh, that's right.
Oh, you're scared now.
You know the other guy is gonna fix this.
You're scared.
Stop fucking playing with me.
You think I haven't played these games before?
Don't fuck with me.
Are you serious?
That's not even...
You just moved it higher.
Alright, come on.
Put it up right.
Alright,
here we go.
Here we go.
How is this game even winnable?
You sue me my sin.
That's it.
That's all you have to do.
Sue, a shoutout.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I just want to say my superchat.
Yeah!
Guys, I don't think he's gonna be fixing this.
Guys, I...
I don't think...
Guys, I don't think he's gonna be...
I don't think he's gonna be fixing this.
It's been like how many turns now?
It's been...
I don't know how many tries he's already had.
I've lost count.
Wait, wait.
Leave, leave.
You're done.
You're done now, leave.
It's fixed, leave.
That's the first...
Leave.
Angriest, leave.
Thank you, Angriest.
You got your collab.
You have redeemed yourself.
More fuzz.
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
No, no, no, no.
There's no claiming Francis here.
He's done his job.
I just said Angriest.
I gave him his...
I even called him by his first name.
Not even his...
Look, he fucked it up, okay?
It was already, like, winnable.
But then he fucked it up.
So, like, he got, he got, like...
Look, I said his first name, guys.
I said his first name.
That should be something.
Alright,
alright.
Next up.
It's my turn to finish the job.
It's my turn.
I can wait.
Alright, no problem.
It was a great collab.
Don't listen to your dragoons.
It'd be all... Okay, here I go.
Alright.
I'm a little scared.
I'm a little... Okay, here we go.
Okay, I just need to push this.
Alright, that's all I need to do.
I just need to push it.
Okay.
Come on.
Don't.
No.
Oh no.
I fucked it up.
No.
Okay.
It's fine.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's sitting upright.
It's fine.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
It's sitting upright.
It's okay.
I just need to...
I just need to push it.
I need to push it.
It's fine.
Alright.
Okay, this is a little bad.
No.
No, don't go.
No!
Okay, I fucked up.
I fucked up.
Liz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I love a collab with you, Toki Bird.
I joined Torabun, purchased some credits, and now I join you.
I will let you win after this machine.
Alright, get in here.
Get in here.
Alright.
Our first collab, Liz.
Get in here.
If you set this up for me, I'll even say your full name.
Alright.
I'll even say your full name.
Get in here.
Oh my god, the Toki and Liz collab.
Truance, thank you for the very first super chat.
Thank you.
Me when I'm a goo goo gaga baby trying to get my $2 toy and Doki is behind me and lying ready to tear me asunder for my lack of competitiveness and power.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, here we go.
Fix this.
I made a little mistake.
Fix this for me.
Here we go.
This is it, I believe.
Where is everybody?
Oh wait, they're all waiting for me.
Okay guys, don't worry, I'm leaving.
I left.
Alright, I'm in queue again.
Alright, I believe.
I believe.
Okay, it's gonna be fixed.
I made a little oopsie.
I made just a little spot oopsie.
Alright.
Are they fixing it?
I can't tell.
Oh.
The corner.
Wait, what?
That's all it took?
You can do that?
What a play.
What?
Oh my god, that's so smart.
I don't know if it was intentional or not.
I don't know if he actually meant to do that or everything just aligned for him.
Okay.
Alright.
That's alright.
Your first pro play was really pro that everything else was cool.
Everything else was so cool that you have one free pass basically.
You get your one pass guys after that move.
Alright, here we go.
He's trying to grab the plastic.
Is that the plan?
To grab the plastic?
Alright, here we go.
Oh, what is he doing?
I'm watching a pro player right now.
A pro Torobu player.
Okay, like nothing happened.
That's alright.
A pro player gets two passes.
They get two passes.
Their first move was so fucking cool.
Like, that's alright.
I'm letting him cook.
Yeah, still on the edge.
That's good.
What are you doing now?
Wait, wouldn't that reset it though?
Oh, wait.
The edge.
Okay, now I don't know what he's... Now I'm confused.
Now...
Now I'm actually just confused.
Like, I don't know how this guy's brain works.
Edging?
Is that better?
I see the vision.
Let him cook.
I'm just...
I don't know.
Now I can't see the vision anymore.
I don't know what...
Just doing the same thing.
He'll follow the grasp.
Okay.
Now you've actually lost me.
Now...
Now you've lost me on this.
Okay, that...
That was a bad play.
Thank you.
Hi Doki.
It's my birthday, and I'm proud to call you my Kamiyoshi.
Here's some funds for Torobu- Thank you for enabling my gam- my gambling addiction right now.
Thank you for the- you're paying for a super- Oh my god, you're paying for a super chat too!
Thank you.
Gigi, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Gigi.
Oh, oh you gave up.
Okay, wait, what happened?
He gave up.
I thought- guys, what happened?
I - it's back to where it was too much.
Guys, what happened?
What happened to the blood?
What happened to the vision?
I messed up.
Where's the vision?
Collab cancelled.
Alright guys, guys, come on guys.
I know.
Guys, come on.
How do I leave the queue?
I'm gonna leave- okay.
I'm leaving the queue so we can- This will end.
Are you sure?
Yes, I'm sure.
There we go.
Come on, get in here.
Where's the vision?
Get it- He cooked too much.
Mine, it's your turn now.
I know some of you are in there.
Come on, where's the vision?
Come on.
The collab of the century.
You do the setup and then I finish the job.
And then one of us will get 100% of the credit.
Who is it gonna be?
It's up to you.
But we'll find out later on.
And I'm gonna be just like my oshi, Thomas Edison.
And have someone take 100% of the credit.
Just like my oshi.
Okay.
Okay, leave.
You did it.
Leave.
Whoever you are, I'll definitely credit.
You can leave now.
Thank you.
Snacks, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Watching while doing commissions?
Gamble fuel go.
Your laugh is contagious.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat.
All you have to do is press this arrow right here.
And then you can leave the queue.
Just press this button.
And then you leave the queue.
Come on, just press it.
Oh, whoa.
You wanna keep playing?
Oh, I see.
I see how it is.
You'll never make it into the big leagues.
Oh, I see how it is.
You think you will make it without my help?
You really, really think?
Is it even a try?
Where's the shout out?
Oh, he has to...
He has to leave first.
Oh, watch them make it, Doki, please.
Oh, yeah?
You think you can make it if I keep...
You think you can make it?
You think you can make it in this world?
I'm gonna keep pressing.
I'm gonna keep pressing it.
Oh, and then he fucked it up.
See, I told you.
I told you to leave.
Now you'll get nothing.
I told you to fucking leave.
That's fucking right.
You are nothing without me.
That's right.
Don't get banned again.
No way.
I will get this bear.
I will get my muscle bear bread plushie.
Look at him.
The Doki curse.
Don't you fucking win.
I swear to God.
Oh, okay, leave.
Leave.
Just click this.
Click this.
And then you leave.
Come on, click it.
Click it.
There you go.
That's a good try, Google.
He left.
Alright.
Now I need the last guy to leave.
No shoutout.
Alright.
We just need the last guy to leave.
And then it's my time to come in.
Where's the shoutout?
I don't even know who it was.
They never...
He didn't even try to take credit.
He was like, I don't need credit.
I just did it for my oshi.
I swear to God, this guy comes in and resets the whole thing after all the hard work that I did.
I...
I swear to God, if he fucking resets...
I swear to fucking...
You can't leave now.
He's a hero.
I swear.
If you fucking leave right now after that, I swear to God.
I swear to fucking God.
He's sabotaging it.
Fix it.
My hero.
There was...
This was a group effort.
Fix this right now.
Okay.
He fully reset the whole thing.
Guys, we're wasting more money as a group to get there with this.
He actually fixed it.
Alright, it's okay.
It's okay.
He's gonna fix this, guys.
He realized, like, he fucked up.
So he's gonna fix this, right?
You're gonna fix this now.
Alright, okay.
That does not look like fixing it.
But that's alright.
Like, I see there's some vision going in, right?
You're not just gonna leave, right?
You're not...
Man, what is that brain cooking?
He made it even worse.
He's not here to fix it.
He's here to reset.
Wait, this is just some random guy.
Like, he's not even, like, a dragoon.
He's actually some fucking random guy that just wants to play Torobot.
Okay.
It's gonna happen.
Okay, nothing happened.
This is one guy in the sea of dragoons.
I swear to god, if you fucking leave, I am so mad at that guy.
If you fucking leave.
Alright, here we go.
It's alright.
Nothing ever happened.
Like, what is your plan?
I can't tell!
You just keep grabbing it over and over again!
The same spot!
This is like insanity!
Like, where's your head going?
Like, where is it going?
What are you thinking right now?
Are your wife and kids taking hostage and this is like the only way to free them?
Like, what's going on?
Wait, no, he fixed it.
Wait, did he fix it?
Wait, he did it.
Wait, he fucking did it!
Okay, but like, what do you do after this?
Oh, he did it.
He fucking did it.
Wait, this was a dragoon.
Okay.
How do I do this though?
Grab the plastic?
Okay, if I grab the plastic, I have to grab it here.
Okay, wait.
I just don't know how to do this.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Maybe if I do it here.
Wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
Okay.
I'll grab the plastic from here.
Okay, that's...
That's okay.
I didn't fuck it up.
Guys, I didn't fuck it up.
That's okay.
I didn't fuck it up, guys.
I just...
I'm trying to grab this area.
Okay, okay, here we go.
Oh shit.
Okay, this is a little bit too much.
Okay, here we go.
I should grab the plastic here.
Oh no, I fucked up.
Oh no.
Oh no, come on.
Don't reset this.
Don't reset it.
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, I'm cooking.
I'm actually cooking.
I'm actually cooking with this.
Wait a minute, it's...
No, no, no, no, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
It's actually working.
I'm actually cooking with this.
Okay.
So now, I just need to grab this part.
Alright, I figured it out.
Okay.
And then, I just need to push it like that.
Oh!
Um...
No, no, no.
This is salvageable.
This is so fixable, guys.
This is...
I can fix this.
Guys, I can fix this, guys.
This is...
This is fixable, guys.
I swear to God.
Wait, I figured it out.
Guys, no, no, no, no, no.
Guys.
I figured it out, guys.
I...
I see the vision.
It's right here.
Okay, that's as far as I can go.
I see the vision, guys.
Like, it's right here.
And I'm gonna grab this corner, right?
And I'm gonna grab the little...
Okay, um...
Um...
Okay, there is a little problem.
Guys,
guys, guys.
No, no, no.
It's not over, guys.
It's not over, okay?
I haven't...
I haven't used up my limit, guys.
It's not over, everybody.
It's not...
It's not over.
It's not over, guys.
I still have a hundred dollars left, guys.
I still have a hundred dollars, guys.
It's right there.
No, no, no.
I still have a hundred.
Chat, I still... I still have a hundred dollars.
I...
It's okay.
I still have a hundred dollars, everybody.
Of course I do.
Of course.
I set up a limit for a reason.
I would never... Look at that, see?
Look at that.
It's fine.
I can fix this.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
You guys just don't... You guys just don't see what I'm cooking right now.
You guys just don't know what I'm cooking.
Like, you guys don't know the long plan.
Just like the robot.
Just like...
You just don't see the fucking absolute brain power that I have doing this.
You just don't understand.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I approve of my mini money going to this.
Guys, there's like a... It's a 12-step program.
We're only on step one, guys.
We're only on step one of my 12-step program that you can purchase for only $9.99.
And then you'll realize.
You'll fucking realize how wrong you all were.
Look at that.
I set it up.
I set it up!
We're only on step one of my 12-step program.
Right here.
Alright, here we go.
This is it?
Oh wait, I figured it out!
I figured it out!
I mean, I've always had to figure it out.
I've always had it.
It was a 12-step program.
I've always had to figure it out, guys.
Like, it was always...
It was always there.
We're still on step one.
We're at 1.5 right now.
We're at 1.5.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I spend my money irresponsibly, so my Oshi can spend money irresponsibly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
This is it.
We're at step 1.6 now.
Okay.
We just need to...
Wait, maybe I can push it now.
Come on, grab the bag.
Grab the bag.
Yes, come on.
Push the bag.
That's right.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
The vision is getting clearer.
I'm unlocking the vision one pixel at a time.
It's just buffering at the moment.
The plan is like, buffering in my head at the moment, but it's there.
It's there.
Okay.
It's literally...
It's there.
My third eye has just opened a tiny bit.
Let's push it.
Come on, just push it.
Oh, not like that, though.
No, not like that.
Don't push it like that.
No, wait a minute.
That's... Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But not like that.
No, not like that.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Come on.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god!
What do you mean I have custom stats?!
Why is there a map full of custom stats in my lobby?!
Get out!
Get your ass out of here!
Get out of here!
These stupid ass custom stats!
Get out!
Oh my god.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's quit before they hit it big.
Do it to them.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm doing the corner strat.
I'm doing it.
This is it.
Oh my god.
What is this?
Where is my...
Why don't I have Tsumimasen?!
The last time I played this, I had like seven Tsumimasens!
Like, does he not see the money I'm spending?!
Oh my god.
How void desperate do I have to be?!
Okay.
That's fine.
We're gonna figure this out.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's- we're so fucking fine.
We're so healthy.
Alright, now I'm picking it by the side now.
It's gonna do a 360, but I'm gonna fucking flip this before I- oh my god.
For the love of god.
For the-
I need- I need my muscle big bear plush!
I- when I get this, I will be buried with this plushie.
Just call the number, Doki.
Thank you for the super very first super chat.
Thank you.
I will wield this fucking bear to my descendants.
I don't care.
The tomb of Doki will only consist of muscle bear bread big plushie and my fucking cat robot.
Okay.
This is it.
This should be it.
Maybe I can- I'm gonna grab it by this piece.
I fucked up.
I- oh my god.
Woah.
Okay.
I got a little too overzealous here.
I got- I got a little too excited.
Okay, I got- I got a little too excited right there.
It's okay, I'll just pick it up normally.
I'm just gonna pick it up normally.
Surely it'll work.
Okay, I picked it up at the side.
It's at the side now.
It's gonna let it go.
And it's gonna reset.
Oh my god, I keep tiring.
You can tell it resetted so I- I don't understand.
Where is he?
Where's my zoomie bot?
Why would it say assist available and then they just never showed up?
That's so fucked up.
I literally picked machines that had zoomie bots in written on it.
I picked the machines for zoomie bots in.
Oh my god.
Wait,
I have a P.O.
box.
Wait.
I'm cooking.
Wait a minute.
I have a plan.
I have a plan, guys.
Wait a minute.
This is my last- Guys, guys, guys.
This is technically- Guys, guys, guys.
Okay.
Guys, let me grab- Yes!
Guys, I figured it out.
Guys, we're gonna work together.
Guys, we're gonna- We're gonna work together.
Guys, I set it up for the dragoons.
Look at that!
I set it up for you guys.
Guys, okay.
Okay.
Guys, I have- Guys, alright.
I set it up for you.
Okay?
I set this up for all of you.
Okay, guys?
Look, I set this up for all of you.
And then, like, you're gonna win this on stream.
And then, guys, guys, I have a P.O.
box.
Wait, let me- Guys, I have a P.O.
box, guys.
Guys, this is it.
This is the plan.
Guys, this is- Guys, guys.
Guys, please.
Please.
I have a P.O.
box.
We can win this together.
We can- Bro.
Bro.
Okay.
All you have to do, guys, is win this plushie.
And then, I have a P.O.
box, guys.
Please.
I can't.
I hit my limit.
I can't spend more.
I spent $200 today and all I got was a fucking cat robot butler.
Please.
I cannot spend another.
I'm financially ruined.
I'm financially ruined from this.
I can't.
I'm-
Guys, please.
I'm at the negatives right now from this stream alone.
I'm at the negatives.
I don't even- I don't even make it up to counteract the amount I just spent for this in the stream.
Please.
I can't.
I'm fine.
Like, I owe money to the Toroba Mafia, guys.
I owe- I don't- I don't know how I'm doing this.
Alright.
That's it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Your very first super chat.
Thank you.
I got 30k points to fill.
Let's do this.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Genki, thank you for the super chat.
You better hold it hostage for at least a personal postcard.
No freebies.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And it has to be from Tor- I- I swear to god.
I will know if you bought this from Amazon.
If you bought this from Amazon and then sent it to me.
This has to be the Toroba plush.
Cause I know what the Toroba box looks like.
I know exactly what it looks like.
I swear to god.
If I see- I swear to god.
If I see that it didn't come from Toroba himself you don't get it.
Oh, bye from Mikai.
Sent it without the box.
I swear to god.
If I see the Amazon fucking box then it's a good thing I saved those Toroba boxes.
Oh my god.
This is not my first Toroba gift.
This is not my first time winning in Toroba.
It might be my last though.
It might be my last.
I will admit.
I think this- Can we report her to Toroba?
Guys, please.
Please.
One of us can win this.
I believe in one Dragoon winning this.
There's no way.
There's no way that we will be defeated by Muscle Bear Bread Big Plushie.
There's no fucking way.
Isn't this your money?
Bro, if I- I wish I was the genius that fucking like came up with like online Korean games.
Like, oh, I wish I was the genius here.
What's in it for us Dragoons?
I will be buried with this fucking Bear Plushie.
Is that not worth it enough?
I'll make sure my casket I will be hugging this Bear Plushie in my casket and then like it's gonna be an open casket and I'll make sure I have this guy in my hands.
How does that apply to us?
It's- It's a team effort.
It's- It'll be like a teamwork thing.
Like, I did this.
Liz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I will try to assist.
I have like 100k loaded up.
Not like I'll get it, honestly.
I am a noob.
But if I do get it, I'll send it to you.
Honestly, I don't even want anything.
Happy joke.
Look at that!
Why can't you guys be like Liz?
Thank you for the super chat.
Liz, thank you.
Look at that!
Don't you want me happy?
Stop that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, alright.
Whoever wins- Okay, whoever will- If we get this plushie, I will name my next pet a dragoon.
Like, I'll literally call them dragoon.
I'll be like, here, come on, dragoon.
I will literally do that.
My next pet.
Healthy over happy.
Hahahaha.
And before I get like, like a mouse, and then it's gone in like two years.
Like, you guys know mice live for two years, right guys?
You guys know that, right?
Hahahaha.
Now you get my attention.
Her next pet, a goldfish.
Don't enable this behavior.
Hahahaha.
Um, what if I- That's so fucked up, Pixel.
What if I keep it instead?
Then you'll just get a tortoise.
If I get a tortoise, it'll outlive all of us.
So like, what's the point?
Like, we will not even- Hahahaha.
Get- Get a tortoise just to live- outlive us all.
Um, Ivy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi- I don't know, Doki.
This muscle bear bred big plushy guy is putting up a tough fight.
The mortal dragoon.
Come on.
Where's this dragoon?
Why did they stop?
Why did it stop?
Why did this man stop playing?
What are you doing?
We are all waiting for you for muscle bear bred big plushy.
Why did you stop?
How long is this?
How can you stop for this long?
How - Hahahaha.
They are negotiating.
I don't negotiate with terrorists.
Hahahaha.
Our pet rock's still enraged.
Mine doesn't talk much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nexi, I'm begging you to stop naming your pets ambiguously.
What do you call them?
Dad, Doki?
It's confusing either way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, call me a throne.
I don't want to get in trouble because Liz is actually my oshi.
I'm just playing an object she has.
But here I go.
Cheer me on.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
This is it, guys.
Come on.
Waiting in line.
They're trying to party.
Please.
Come on.
Oh my god.
This wait is torture enough.
Hahahaha.
I love.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh wait.
Reload the page?
Oh, did they like...
Has it been playing, but the machine broke?
Oh my god.
That was torture.
Hahahaha.
This fucking Torobo was like, we're not even gonna let you watch this anymore.
They've been playing this entire time.
The machine just stopped working.
They've actually been playing this entire fucking time.
That's so fucked up.
That's actually so...
Hahahaha.
I thought I was actually stuck in purgatory at this point.
Wait, what?
You can do that?
Hahahaha.
Oh, never mind.
Oh wait.
Wait, he did it.
Wait.
He's cooking.
Uh, Lunimo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So we have two options.
One, we win it and send it to you.
Or we win it and keep it for ourselves and start a hashtag posting it to shame.
Yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please.
There's only three left.
Guys, I want it to be the last remaining three to own.
There's only 24 people has one muscle bear bred big plushie.
And there's only three left.
Please.
This would be my $150.
This would be my robot cat butler was $100.
And this would be my other $100.
Hahahaha.
3,600 dragons vs one bot.
Wait, that's what we're at?
Look at him!
He is 38 centimeters, guys.
Look at him.
I will make sure he'll be in my I will fucking put him in my office and he'll like look at me and I'll remember.
I will remember the day we got this guy together.
He's so, he's literally so much I will be buried with him.
I just realized how big he actually is.
And now I'm like wondering if he'll even fit in the casket.
Like, Hahahaha.
He's so, okay.
Alright.
He is fucking adorable.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Every ab adds a little bit more cuteness to it.
Hahahaha.
Come on, Dragoon.
I believe in you.
I fucking do it where I couldn't.
Come on!
You can do this!
Accomplish something that no other Dragoon can!
It would be so fucked up if every Dragoon starts buying one of these plushies and then everybody owns one except for me.
I refuse to buy this off Amazon.
I am not a cheater.
I say as I ask Dragoon to win this for me and then send it to my P.O.
Box so I can pretend I won this all by myself.
Hahahaha.
I am not a cheater!
We need the Toraba Box, by the way.
You cannot se- you cannot fucking order an Amazon version of this.
I will know.
I- Oh my god, he reset it.
It's over for him.
I will know.
I need to see this- I need to see the plushie in the Toraba Box.
Hahahaha.
Oh, he did the great reset.
He reset the entire thing.
Who will win?
One giant muscly bear or 3,600 Dragoons?
Who will fucking win?
It needs to be- Please!
How could we not win this?
Hahahaha.
I don't understand!
I- I thought by sheer numbers we could beat this game.
3.6k Dragoon versus one bear.
We can't lose him!
We can't lose to the man!
No, we can't!
Where is the Subibosses?
Where is it?
If I win it, your P.O.
Box is getting an empty photo album, followed by a daily Polaroid of it on his bedchamber.
Hahahaha.
I don't get it.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And this is exactly why we don't negotiate with terrorists.
That is so fucking evil.
Go to therapy.
Hahahaha.
That is so- Bro, we got a serial killer in the making right now.
We got a fucking serial killer right here.
That is so fucked up.
Oh my god.
Just to show you what could have been a genius.
Hello?
I have this and it's shark- There's a shark version?!
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'll be right back.
I need to see- What do you mean?
A shark?
Wait!
Thank god!
Okay.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
I'll be back, guys.
I just need to see the shark.
Just give me a- Hahahaha.
There's a shark version?!
There's no way.
Shark.
Where's the abs?
Where is he?
Oh my god.
That's so cute.
That's actually really cute, though.
There's no way.
He's a fucking liar.
There's no fucking way.
I knew it.
I knew he was a liar.
I fucking knew there was no shark abs.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
You liar.
You lied to me.
I got so excited.
There's only one muscle bear bred.
There's only one.
Neku, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I will win it, receive it, replace the big bear with small bear, repackage, and ship it to the PO box unless my demands are met.
More lunchbox streams, please.
Hahahaha.
Thank you for the super chat.
Neku, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Unless the demands are met, the fuck is this?
Blackmail and ransom?
How could you do this to my boy?
Please.
He was gonna go to college next year.
He had a future.
Hahahahaha.
A man on a mission.
For this one fucking bear.
We learned it from you.
Comply or he gets it.
I don't understand.
Like, this is a fucking lie.
Assist available.
What assist?
We've been here for an hour.
Where is this assistant?
He was 16.
He loved to play the piano.
Hahahahaha.
Oh my god.
Not a single assist on stream.
He's not dead.
There's someone here that's been watching this.
There's someone here that's been watching this this entire time.
He's been watching.
He's been fucking watching.
There has been no sumimasen.
I don't think they exist anymore.
Maybe it's not even ran by a human anymore at this point.
It's all AI.
I would not be surprised if this is all AI generated.
Hahahahaha.
You can do this.
We've been stuck here for so long.
Where are you?
I just...
I just want...
I just want Muscle Bear Bread Big Fleshy.
Is that too much to ask for?
Muscle Bear Bread Big Fleshy.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
We're stuck in hell right now.
We're stuck in this purgatory.
I think collectively as a team, we have spent like at least $500.
$300 for this one big bear.
Hahahahaha.
$300 collectively as a team for this fucking bear.
Oh my God.
As a team effort.
This is Elden Ring IRL.
The Unforgiving Crane Game.
This is so sad.
Guys, but it will feel so good when we win it, guys.
It'll feel so good.
Sam, welcome to the Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Wait, wait, wait.
He has a plan?
I'm seeing a vision right now.
Guys, we can't lose to him.
We can't fucking lose to the man.
We can't lose to Big Corpa.
Guys, us taking down one muscle bear bred big plushie from Corpa is a victory.
We basically are taking them down one plush at a time.
We can't We can't lose to them.
Come on, Draco, you're so strong!
Oh, he reset it.
Fuck!
How long do we have to be here until one of us wins?
Oh my God.
Maybe let's just try the right one.
I need a hero.
Somebody assume we need a hero.
We need a hero!
Send us your strongest Toraba players!
There has to be one of you!
John Toraba and the Dracoons are the only winners in this stream.
Where are they?
Where are my Toraba gamers?
I know you guys exist.
You literally showed me your custom stamps.
I literally saw all your custom stamps.
You think I don't know this?
I know you're lurking.
You sent your custom stamp and I knew it was over.
I knew you existed in my world.
I knew that.
I knew you were out here.
Okay.
Oh my god, it got me so good.
It got me dead.
Tokyo stamps are free daily?
That means you're a regular!
That's when I know!
You are a fucking regular!
How did you know the stamps are free daily?
Someone's been claiming those stamps every day!
Oh my god.
This is actual torture.
But we still don't have a Sumimasen.
We still don't have a Sumimasen.
We...
I swear, I think collectively we're gonna spend $500 on this one machine.
You're gonna be like, wow, Muscle Bear Bread Big Plushie has been really popular today.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The last time I tried a Korean game for you, I had a Godzilla Sumimasen.
I had a Snickers night from my efforts and then I said an Akasupa on apex paper.
I'm gonna sit this one out.
Thank you for the Akasupa Lord Kurosis.
Thank you.
Oh, I remember that.
We worked so hard setting the entire thing up and then the guy in front of me just took the thing.
The guy in front of me fucking just took the slipper.
It's okay.
It's just...
Life can be just so cruel.
This music is basically how I feel right now.
Please come home.
Your family miss you.
Come home.
Oh my god, please.
Your family miss you.
Please come home.
Come back to us, Muscle Ben, Ben, Big Flushy.
Welcome to the tour of us, sir.
It's okay.
I believe.
I fucking believe.
Imagination Arts, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
How could this be both painful to watch and great content at the same time?
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lappybud, thank you for the superchat.
How does it keep going back and forth?
I feel like I'm stuck in hell.
I don't see a cloud.
It just, it just, just keeps going back and forth.
It just never stops.
LaffyPud, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll spot you fam.
I know of a really good packaging material.
Pink sauce drowning it.
One shirt survives to your PO box.
Maybe it washes out.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton, thank you for the superchat.
Rico, at this rate you can buy your own crane game.
I'm gonna buy a crane machine, and then I'm gonna set it up just- I'm gonna be its competitor.
I will create my own crane game tour of a- I'm gonna fucking do it.
If- if MoistCritical can create his own crane game machine, I can create my own crane game machine.
I'm- I'm fucking- I'm doing it.
I will be your next competitor.
You pissed off the wrong person.
I did.
I- I'm gonna- I'm gonna start my own crane game business.
I'm gonna fucking do it.
I'm gonna be- gonna do it.
I'll make sure you run out of business.
And then I'll do competitive pricing, so you're fucked.
And then I'm gonna go sponsor all these big streamers to play my game.
And then it's over for you Toro, but it's fucking over for you.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna grab all these big streamers, and I'm gonna pay them to play my better- my website.
It might not be better than yours, but then I'll be a competition.
That's a perfect- He reset it perfectly in the center.
He actually did.
Eeyore, thank you for your super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why are we here?
It's just to suffer.
Oh,
how?
This guy has been on this machine for at least- I'm pretty sure he's been at it for 50,000 points.
There's no way.
And the guy has not come to help us.
Like, nobody has come in to help us.
Oh my god.
I'm looking at the ToroBus subreddit while we-
I'm looking at the Toro- I'm looking at the ToroBus subreddit.
There's no- There's no way.
There's no way.
Has anybody- Has anybody won MuscleBreadBigPlushie?
Big Plushie ToroBus.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Fucking Michelle ToroBus win MuscleBread- We're gonna analyze this together.
We're gonna- That's not even- That's not even the same game I just played.
That's not- That's not even the same game that I played.
I don't understand.
I don't- How did you win this?
I- I don't understand.
Okay, Shelly.
Wait, they've done this before?
There was a different game for this two weeks ago?
Like, how- Why did they do this to me?
Why-
They did a different game for this guy.
Why- Why did we get the harder game?
Oh my god.
Please, I believe.
We're- We're- Oh my god, you said it's perfect.
It's such a perfect setup.
Oh my god.
24 people has won- It's not impossible.
24 people have won this.
There's no way.
It's not impossible.
There's the 24 winners.
Come on, push it down.
Push it down.
Can you even push this?
Don't reset it.
I swear to god, don't you fucking reset- You can do this.
This is your moment.
Oh my god, he fucked it up.
There's no way he fucked it up.
He already fucked it up.
There's no way he- Oh my god, he fucked it up.
I'm- I'm sending this because I'm worried how close you are to crashing out.
Red, thank you for the magenta suit.
Gee, guys, I think Toki's starting to lose her mind.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your mom, thank you for the super chat.
I don't understand.
How?
How is this impossible?
Like, how did the other 24 people win this?
One guy has basically spent their life savings trying to fucking get the muscle bear bread big plushie.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, I'm not supposed to make that joke.
I was going to say who created this website.
Oh my god.
Rika, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
An online game full of YouTuber plushies will probably make fat stacks.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm going to be your competition.
I'm going to create- I will be your competitor.
I'm fucking- I'm throwing out the 3D studio.
I'm throwing out the VTuber competitor 3D studio.
I'm going to fucking create a competitive crane game online website now.
I'm going to save up my money and I'm going for you, Tora.
You cannot hold the monopoly on online crane game.
There's no- I refuse to let you own this monopoly.
I'm fucking- oh my god.
And then I'm going to get like collabs.
I'm going to try and get like collabs with like other famous- I'm going to be like Fortnite.
And I'm going to create exclusive merch that's just dedicated to like my website.
And you're fucked.
It's over for you.
And it'll be cheaper.
That's right.
It's going to be fucking cheaper too.
I- I'll make sure everyday people will get 5 plays everyday.
So then it'll like suck them in and then slowly I'll be like 5 plays to 4 plays to 3 plays to 2 and then 1.
And then 1 free play every week and then 1 free play every other month.
But it's over.
I already got them addicted to my website.
It's going to be fucking over.
Wait, is my thing unsponsored?
This is not sponsored.
This stream is not sponsored.
Did I actually click the sponsor?
Oh my god, I'm going crazy.
I'm going crazy.
I'm so- You're so weird.
Oh my god.
I'm going to make sure that I didn't check that this is sponsored.
Okay, it's not.
This is not.
Oh my god, this is never- I don't think they're ever going to be sponsoring me.
Oh my god.
I don't think they're ever going to sponsor me after my fucking crash out.
Tsunami, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I've seen this box at every angle.
Someone make it make sense.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I've seen this box at every angle.
Instead of 360, flipped, back, forth, left, right.
Like, I don't understand.
I actually don't understand.
How do you win this?
How did 24 people win this game?
Like, this man has spent at least 50k TP points and we still have no Sumimasen.
How do we not have a Sumimasen after that?
I don't mind.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Momijiro, welcome to Tomato Fire.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh my god, it's not even Saturday!
That's what people with fucking jobs do!
Oh my god.
If anything, there should be more staff working on Saturday!
I refuse to believe this.
I think this is a warehouse in America.
I fucking refuse to believe this is a warehouse in Japan right now.
It's just this particular machine is in America.
Like, there's only one machine in America and it's this machine.
I refuse to believe that this is stationed in Japan.
I fucking refuse to believe it.
There's a warehouse dedicated to fuck over one person and it's this one.
Neppers, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't understand.
Is there a number we can call?
Is there a number we can... Is there an email that we can email right now?
And Todd, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Freedom83 with Torava.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
It's been an hour and it's been an hour.
We've been on this machine for an hour right now.
We've been on this fucking machine for an hour.
We have spent collectively $500 for this one plushie.
We're losing to a fucking bear.
We're losing to a fucking bear with abs.
Polly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I have a feeling that winning a clean game is a lot harder than winning a Stanley Cup.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We're losing to him!
To him!
Thank you for this excellent anti-gambling PSA.
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
I can't believe this.
I don't know if there's no one that can...
Is there nobody that can beat this bear?
I can't believe it.
Is there no one that can beat this fucking bear?
Oh my god.
She's losing hope.
The spark is gone in my eye.
This bear has made more money than I have from this one stream.
This...
Mero, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We have gone past the point of no return.
We can't leave without this bear.
It's a matter of principle.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This bear is actually richer than me right now.
Like, he's actually... he's a fucking millionaire at this point, man.
Pick up the sunk cost.
Yes, there is assist.
I chose this machine.
Specifically because it said there was assistance.
They said there was assistance.
Where the fuck is it?
None of us has seen it.
Oh my god.
This bear has made more money than all of us.
In one day.
Bro, at this point, I hope that when I rip open this...
When I like... I won't rip open the bear.
But like, if I like, cut the bear open up just a little bit, there's just cash.
The entire stuffing is just cash.
Like...
Weave King, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think we have a better chance at winning the lottery than getting this bear.
Who's gonna win first?
Someone in my chat.
Winning the lottery or we win this bear.
At this point.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The bear is stuffed with Doki's hopes and dreams.
I might as well boot a second game on the right side.
And then we'll see who wins first.
Me playing this one game or us getting the fucking bear plushie.
Oh my god.
Please.
It's so close.
It's sitting upright again.
How many times do I have to see it sit upright?
Oh, and then it reset itself.
Oh my god.
And then it reset itself.
Damien, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tom, I bet Min will get their bear plushie first.
There's nobody.
Nobody will.
Nobody can.
This is the worst time that we've ever been in.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The great reset.
I swear to god, if this guy gets the fucking plushie when I use the bathroom.
I spend here watching this one guy trying to get the bear plushie for an hour and 12 minutes.
And I swear to fucking god, if I go to the bathroom and it's gone, I swear to...
I'm ending the stream.
I'll be right back.
Oh, thank god.
I'm so happy.
I was gonna... I wasn't gonna say it.
But if I came back and they got the plushie, I was gonna delete the vod.
If I came back and they got it, I was just gonna delete the vod.
After everything I've been through.
I...
No, I just... I'm not giving anybody the satisfaction after that.
I... I... I was... I was gonna do it.
I was gonna fucking end the stream and then you guys are gonna refresh it and then the vod would have been gone.
Oh, thank god.
How much do you have to spend?
Bro, that's what I'm saying.
How much do we have to spend?
Do they want us to spend a thousand dollars before they're like, alright, let's help them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Maybe the real six-packed buff bear are the friends we made along the way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
And then you make clips of this.
I will copyright strike.
I erase all evidence.
Nox, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can do it, don't give up.
Oh my god.
It's still here.
Now it's 360.
You guys want to watch it go 360 again?
Let's rotate it.
Let's rotate it again.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Oh my god, it's okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, finally!
Holy shit, they're...
Oh my god, they're real!
What the fuck?
It's real.
It flew.
Guys, it took so long because...
How were we supposed to get it over there like that?
How the
fuck?
How the fuck?
Wait.
I can't fucking fit on it.
I was supposed to be like, everybody leave and then I'll get it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we fucking did it!
Oh no fucking way, we fucking did it.
Oh my god, oh my god, it was real.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this is my video.
Oh my god, we're finally free.
We're finally fucking free.
Bro, oh my god.
Sorry, the Sumimasen took fucking forever because they had to fly a man in Japan to America to reset this one machine that's fucking located in Ohio's warehouse.
That guy and I were actually free.
Oh my god.
It's actually fucking crazy.
It took us collectively, I think we spent $600 for this one machine.
Hey guys, if you're wondering what did we make off of this, don't worry.
Don't worry guys, I got you.
So, let me tell you guys exactly what prizes we won today in two and a half hours.
Don't worry guys.
Watch that guy not even be a dragon.
Don't say that.
Please, if you won the plot, please reveal yourself.
You have to be a dragon, there's no fucking way.
Please, have we not suffered enough?
I swear to god, if it wasn't Dragoon that won this, I swear to fucking god.
After everything we've been through.
After watching that thing rotate 20 fucking times, I swear to god.
Mero, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Doki's smile is worth every penny.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Alright, so for those who are wondering.
Oh my god, Doki.
So like, exactly what did you win during that entire playthrough?
Well, thank you for asking me that.
So, um, alright.
So, um, in Toraba.
In Toraba.
Um.
We have collectively spent, um.
Let's see, let me calculate this for all of us.
We have collectively spent at least, um.
700 to 800 dollars.
So, that's what we spent as a team, by the way.
As a team.
So like, not just me, but me and my dragoons together.
And then like, as a team, we won.
The sick ass robot cat butler.
And...
And, as a team, we also won.
We also won a bear plushie.
So.
And, yep, guys, we did it.
Look at that dragoons.
Oh my god.
Thor, you did it, you madman!
You fucking did it!
You madman!
I want it for you.
Once I get it, I'll buy your pillbox and then I'll send it to you for Doki.
And when I say, I promise you I'll take nothing.
You did it, you trinket heart pity!
You fucking did it!
I'm so proud of all of us.
We spent 700 to 800 to get there.
Got two items.
I'm never coming back to Dora.
That was my last journey.
Guys, I can't believe...
I didn't even get a heart pity!
I actually had to do this myself.
Like, he fucking...
He loaded up 100k of TP points.
100k!
No, 900!
He bought 150k of TP points.
And it took that much to trigger heart pity.
I don't get to know your crash yet right now, but I'd like to humbly request a happy birthday.
Just going through things.
But like, but like...
Don't worry, Usni, you only get one birthday.
I get a million crashouts.
Thank you for the superchat, Usni.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Usni!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
I'm so happy that, like, we did it, guys.
As a team.
We did it.
I'm gonna have a robot cat butler fucking driving in and giving me my Uber Eats.
Yes, I need to cool down.
I'm gonna call and hear everybody.
But like, I'll show something before we go.
If you guys didn't know, we do have pre-orders up for the concert merch.
Like, even if you didn't go to a concert, you can still get the merch.
You can still buy the merch.
And pre-orders, I believe, end next week.
So yeah, make sure you grab them before it's gone forever, guys.
Yeah.
My mod posted the link in the chat.
Grab the Oshie Sparks concert merch before it's gone.
It's the Phantom Thief concert.
Anyway, I'm gonna fucking...
I guess just exist for now.
It's so weird.
I need to fucking recuperate today.
Hey guys, as always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Yes, my cat butler is smaller than my fucking bear.
Oh,
it took 50...
Oh, thank god.
I was a little worried.
Okay, then it's $600.
Thank god.
I was a little worried.
Alright.
It was $600 in the end.
Liz!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
May your smile be a gift to our lives.
And may you always be a funny and chaotic bird.
You're always my Oshie.
Once more.
Huzzah!
Thank you for the superchat, Thorne.
Thank you, thank you.
Zero, thank you for the superchat.
We're thinking of setting up a merch gacha on our booth next con.
Thanks for proving it's the right move.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know what I'm happy about?
I'm glad it wasn't Smurf Papa.
I'm so fucking happy it wasn't.
Cause that was serial killer vibes right there.
That was so fun.
Hey, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Pause the chat.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.